[Music]
Science Week in Berlin I think it's a
spectacular idea and you're doing it so
health the idea is to have people from
all over the world celebrate Science in
Berlin for a couple of days
[Music]
it's just the perfect place to discuss
the power of ideas coming from science
in building our future societies
[Music]
we want to explain different science
concepts and talk a bit of what we do in
the lab as Sciences media to engage the
public and also to discuss and engage
the next generation as scientists we
have to help explain why in science is
important and having a science week
creates those kinds of opportunities if
the public has a sense of how to judge
evidence through an encounter with
science it will empower citizenship and
civic participation you get an overview
from so many different areas
this is a great opportunity for us to
also not only share the science but also
to share the technologies that are
emerging from the research that we're
conducting we're doing very complicated
stuff but we're doing excite yourself
and we want to have the people see that
and get as excited as we are
I think is a great opportunity for
interaction and exchanges that will
improve our world how important it is to
really consider science as a whole you
can feel the diversity people come from
all over the world not just for one
meeting but they can choose a set of
meetings throughout the course of a week
[Music]
[Music]
if you get the chance to do that as a
scientist you never miss it
the Berlin Science Week brings really a
focus on what matters so much science
diplomacy at its best it's truly
exciting and inspiring oh it's great
there's so many people here from all
around the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
presents a photo say designs become
[Music]
you